[Music]
today's question comes from lissa
in new york she writes i recently left
my career as a management consultant and
am considering a couple different
options to create my own business
i have forty 42 000 in credit card debt
but i have 45
000 in cash on hand to pay it off what
should i do
pay off all my debt and hope to get a
business loan later or use my savings to
begin the business opportunities that
will generate
an ongoing income stream within six
months well we don't have to know all
the details of this to say of course we
don't want you to take out business debt
business loans are just like personal
loans in the fact that they're debt
and they're bad and they're a risk and
they're yours and you have to be the one
to pay them so we don't
recommend that ever the good news is uh
lissa you have
savings to be able to pay off that debt
and become debt free
you'll still have three thousand dollars
in cash on hand to start your
uh emergency fund your fully funded
emergency fund which would be three to
six months of expenses and then you save
up to
cash flow whatever business growth or
startup costs you may need the thing
that i would challenge if i
had this on the phone when i would ask
what is your business
and what cost do you really have because
a lot of times dave i get this kind of
question and people think oh i need
fifty thousand dollars to start my
business i need ten thousand dollars for
my business and you don't
you don't in many industries you don't
some you might need some startup costs
but in many of them you can start with
your
baby version of your idea your scrappy
version of your idea
and as the business is validated and you
get cash into the business that cash
can fund the growth you started this
this organization on a card table in
your living room
yeah and i we don't know what her
business is she was a management
consultant before
and if you're going into consulting you
don't need much money you need yeah yeah
you need a computer and some consulting
gigs it's your it's your services you're
charging for there
that's the thing so you don't have to
have a lot now so i completely agree
christie and
it'd be ridiculous to pass the credit
card debt turn and take about business
loans that's just trading
that's just a dog chasing his tail
you're just trading one for the other
you're just you're you're kidding
yourself
you didn't really do anything you just
swapped hands um
so what i what i would the only thing i
might
consider but you'd have to make a really
tough case for it
and i would argue with you i'll warn you
ahead of time that let's say you had a
business
and you said all right i need ten
thousand dollars worth of
equipment there's no possible way
not just to be optimal but there's no
possible way to start without
some inventory some equipment something
and uh out of forty thousand
and you could show me how you can make
10 000 back in two months
yep as and i and you have to make me
believe you and believe me i'm gonna i'm
gonna
i'm gonna push you hard on it okay
because it's what i would do if somebody
worked for me came in here and said i
want to spend ten thousand
and um i would say okay where are we
gonna make that money back because
that's the whole idea of business is if
you're gonna spend money
but putting ten thousand dollars on a
five-year payout
and calling that a bus that's dumb
that's just dumb
so you would need an almost
instantaneous break even to sell me on
that idea
but if you could do that i would say pay
off the top 32 000 of your debt snowball
put 10 000 in the business and then two
months later you're debt-free yeah
that would be okay yeah but but you'd
have to really prove it
and it's not i want to open my business
and this is optimal
i mean it's like you have a computer i
want a better computer that's that's you
don't need that you don't have to do
that i want to be a photographer and i
already have a camera but i want a
better camera
no no this is what i spend my life
around ramsay doing
all the time if somebody wants to do
something i said we'll make something
with what we've got right we have all
these things and
would be optimal i know it'd be optimal
but you know optimal doesn't equal
profit
optimal equals spending money yeah and
when you spend money it lowers your
profit this is a
business equation here people so really
really good
question you've got we don't have the
nuance and the details of your situation
but
the the concept being here no debt
know-how no way start something
and you are the secret sauce not the
crap you would buy with some of this
money
i had a question dave you've been
talking about no debt for over 30 years
and you still regularly get questions
should i take out this loan
it's not just new people either it's not
just people that like it's their first
time calling in first time listen to the
show
do you think that they think they're
going to get a different answer no
no they they want someone to say it out
loud for them okay if they're it now she
could be new
sure i mean she could have just joined
us on youtube a month ago sure that's
possible
but the number of people that calling
i've listened here for five years and
i'm thinking about getting a car loan
you know
yeah and we're like no no you really
weren't listening were you
but we want to be snarky and sometimes
we are but uh
but but overall but what happens is is
that they were listening and all this
stuff kind of worked over here
and then they have this new situation
and it's different
it feels like it's different it's
different
or i really know i shouldn't do it but
it's like i'm going to let those people
on ramsey show be my conscience
speak they're going to speak into my
head the little angel on my shoulder
going
don't do it right where all the devils
are out there in the world going oh yeah
it's no big deal to borrow money you get
the airline miles on your credit card no
that bull crap you know
yeah and so that that's um but you know
we get to be the angel on the shoulder
sometimes
but but um yeah it is as if
we were inconsistent or something yeah
we're not we get it all the time always
get the same answer